das Grundstück ist ungefähr 5000
Quadratmeter groß ist ein ganz schön
großer Garten aber es ist jetzt nicht
kein riesengroßer Bauernhof also wir
werden da jetzt kein
landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb aufmachen
sondern es ist einfach ein
Selbstversorger Hof und ja wir wollen
mehr Tiere ich würde erstmal mit
scharfen anfangen weil ich will auch
super gerne wieder melken ich vermisse
das so toll unsere eigenen Milchprodukte
herstellen zu können also früher haben
wir auch unseren eigenen Käse gemacht
eigenen Joghurt ziegeneis selber gemacht
natürlich hatten wir unsere eigene Milch
und das ist einfach schon ein anderes
Level von Selbstversorgung und da will
ich auf jeden Fall wieder